it's great to welcome to the program
today rent Nancy rosenbloom who is a
Harvard University Department of
Government professor emeritus
the book a lot of people are saying
co-written with Russell Muirhead
Nancy so great to have you on the
program I'm delighted to be with you
David so I think an interesting place to
start would be we talk a lot about
conspiracy theories conspiratorial
thinking on the program we've looked at
some of the psychological mechanisms
that impact people getting into this
type of thinking but one thing we've not
discussed so much is whether from a sort
of objective empirical point point of
view conspiratorial type thinking is
increasing in society so let's maybe
start there do we have any strong
evidence one way or the other about
whether in general this type of thought
is more prevalent today than it has been
in the past I don't think we have more
evidence of its prevalence I think we
can say two things with with some
confidence one is that the spread of
conspiracy thinking probably has
increased because of the Internet it's
costless and speedy to spread these
kinds of rumors or claims and that gives
us a reason it's hard to count on the
Internet as you probably know but it
gives us reason to think that more
people are at least exposed to these
things whether or not they're true
believers I think the other thing I can
say with confidence because it's the
theme of my book is that there is a new
kind of conspiracy thinking out there
today and it's not conspiracy theory as
we understand it it's conspiracism
without the theory the two have become
decoupled and this really is a new and
malignant phenomenon in politics it's
brought conspiracy thinking in from the
fringe right into the White House and
the halls of power and it has I think a
different significance and different
effect than classic conspiracy theory
well so can we first define the
difference what would be and maybe
examples would be good when we talk
about conspiracy theorizing versus
conspiracism what
the distinction between the two well a
conspiracy theory is a theory we should
take that part of the phrase seriously
that is it offering an explanation of
things and conspiracy theories theorists
do a lot of rigorous work they collect
the dots they amass evidence they find
patterns in this evidence they develop a
grand narrative and sometimes these
conspiracy theories are actually true
and sometimes they're completely
fantastic and unwarranted and often
they're a vexing mix of the two but in
any case these people are like
researchers they are making an argument
based on evidence and they want you to
think that this argument is true that
the unintelligible the previously
unintelligible has been made
intelligible by their findings and that
the unbelievable has been made
believable so for example a conspiracy
theorist has an account of the real
assassination of John F Kennedy right or
a conspiracy theory about the real
sources of the 9/11 attack that it
wasn't nineteen men operating out of the
remote quarters of Afghanistan it was
the US government or drones or whatever
it was so that's a conspiracy theory
it's an explanation and in a way
conspiracy theorists reason the same way
we all reason when we want to make an
argument about something that's
happening in the world the new
conspiracism really is entirely
different it's conspiracy without theory
and it doesn't attempt to clean plate
explain anything there are no dots there
are no patterns there's no evidence
there's no argument instead what you
have is a bare assertion the election is
rude for example or the Lula report is
an attempt at a coup d'etat
so it's bare assertion sometimes it
takes the form of I'm just asking
questions you know what I know is bad
enough people would say about the birth
or conspiracy what I know is bad enough
but I'm just asking questions what I
really want is to know a lot more or
they or they take it takes the form of a
kind of attribution like some agent of
government is plotting something
it's an insidious plot it's clearly
ominous it's something worse than sort
of partisan bias or self-interest but
there's no explanation of who or why or
for what purpose
so it's conspiracism without without the
explanation and there's a way in which
this conspiracism without the
explanation is very powerful yeah well I
was going to ask is one more pernicious
than the other or dangerous than the
other because you you might imagine that
with a particular conspiracy theory you
can at least attempt to take the theory
head-on present you know a contradictory
narrative ask for that evidence ask what
might change your mind about this
particular theory it seems that with
conspiracism more generally it could be
more difficult to disabuse someone of
those beliefs I think that that's
exactly exactly right then I made the
point earlier the conspiracy theory
reasons the way we reason these kinds of
bear assertions like the election is
rigged are completely disorienting
they're disorienting and unnerving
because they um they they completely
change the what it means for us to know
something because they come without
argument they come just with insistence
and when we can't when and so it changes
as I say what it means to know something
and it's very hard to answer it the
other thing that makes it much more
dangerous of course is that it's coming
from the Office of the President or from
elected representatives or from from
governor's and so on and of course from
conspiracy entrepreneurs who spread it
and there's a third thing that makes it
I think more potent than conspiracy
theory and that that it uses the
Internet in a different way conspiracy
theorists use the internet to find their
dots and their evidence right architects
and engineers for 9/11 truth look up the
the escalating temperature of jet fuels
for example or the capacities of drones
whereas the new conspiracists used the
internet really very differently to
spread their
ideas and when you make a bare assertion
it's easy to spread right you can do it
in two hundred and eighty characters
easily you're not offering an
explanation and they use assent to this
theory as validation what validates it
is not the argument but validates it is
a lot of people are saying and that's
the title of the book so and you can in
a sense count the number of retweets or
likes or shares and so you can say a lot
of people are saying that the Obama
administration tapped the phones of
Trump Tower during the campaign yeah my
sense when I talk to conspiracy
theorists is that they do care and are
genuinely invested in the truth or
falsity of what their assertions are
exactly how how does that compare to
conspiracism because with some of these
conspiracists ideas I am less convinced
that those espousing the ideas are
actually invested in the truth but
rather are invested merely in the spread
of the of the general notion for their
benefit I think that that's very
perceptive of you David and here's
here's how I understand it um when the
president for example makes conspiracist
claim that the Justice Department is
planning a coup the people who follow
him who are sent to it who spread it who
repeated don't necessarily think that
all of the elements or all of the facts
have to be true they think that they are
the phrase that we use is that this
claim is true enough that is it fits
with their political hostilities and
political animosities and political
connections so that the story is true
enough if you think that Hillary Clinton
is evil and does horrible things and
lies about it then the pizza gay
conspiracy which says that she's running
a child sex trafficking ring out of the
basement of a pizza parlor in Northwest
Washington DC they don't necessarily
have to believe that all of those facts
are true what they believe is it's true
enough and let me read you because this
confirms
your hypothesis here let me read you a
couple of quotes about what true enough
really sounds like so a Republican
representative in Congress was asked
about the allegation that the Democratic
Party had actually conspired to create
that clash between white nationalists
and protesters in Charlottesville in
1917 and that representative said I'm
not saying it's true but I'm saying it's
completely plausible
another example when Sarah Huckabee
Sanders was asked about Trump's tweet of
a video that falsely purported to show a
Muslim immigrant assaulting someone she
said whether it's a real video the
threat is real and this is the point
that is true enough so probably there
were some believers who think every
element of something like pizza gate is
true and in fact an armed gunman went to
the pizza parlor and shot up the place
because he went to rescue the children
but most I think do not I think that
this new conspiracism and the assent to
it and the validation through tweeting
and liking and affirming and so on is a
sort of form of political participation
yeah well I was going to say that
there's this there's this
rationalization that often exists which
is it's less important whether this is
specifically true because belief in this
serves is sort of a means to an end even
if this particular assertion is not true
and I think that that's how a lot of
conspiracists rationalize continuing to
spread stuff that even they question the
truth of I think that's right and so
then the question becomes why is this so
dangerous what's happening I mean we
could look back and say it's absurd we
could say it says new instead of
malignant form of political expression
but we haven't gotten that why it's
really dangerous why we should care
about it and why I think it's one of the
most prominent and unders under assessed
elements of American politics today the
spread of conspiracism and I think that
what it does besides disorienting us is
to D legitimate foundational democratic
institutions and are the most obvious is
all
kinds of knowledge producing
institutions have been diligent amazed
by these conspiracists claims the most
obvious and publicized is fake news fake
news doesn't just say that they're
erroneous or making a partisan stories
fake news really says that there's a
conspiracy in the mainstream media to
denigrate the administration and that
it's that the newscasters are enemies of
the people but that's just the most
obvious every time when Trump says for
example that he had the biggest
inaugural crowd in history and then the
National Park Service photograph showed
that it was a modest crowd what did he
do he said that the that the National
Park Service doctored the photographs
this is a conspiracist claim and it
undermines the meaning and the value and
the authority of the National Park
Service and the same thing is true when
he attacks the FBI or National
Intelligence Estimates when the National
Intelligence director Dan coats issued
his annual threat assessment and said
the climate changed had become a
security threat for a variety of reasons
the administration said he should go
back to school what is the National
Intelligence director now so we have
this cumulative deal adjudication of all
kinds of knowledge producing
institutions and we need them because
you cannot make political decisions and
policy decisions without some confidence
that facts matter and conspiracism is a
better more permanent more powerful I
think way of dealing debating these
institutions and the facts that they
assess then lives
Trump's lies come and go for example
they are fact-checked or they're not but
they're hard to keep up with I think the
New York Times said something like
10,000 recently yeah his conspiracist
plans and the ones that are supported by
his followers and by many Republicans
today they're pretty permanent the same
ones go on and on they have traction he
comes back to them again and again and
they do this D legitimation Nancy in the
limited time we have left I'd love to
just briefly hear what are the
techniques if there are any
that you have found to be effective in
getting people away from conspiracist
beliefs and a sort of conspiracies
framework well to some extent it's the
same as combatting lies I mean there's a
kind of fact-checking that can go on I
would insist that you will never get at
the people who are supporting Trump and
other conspiracies claims for political
reasons right this is a kind of
entrenched polarization so the question
is can you immunize or give some
confidence to the rest of the public who
really gets sort of disoriented by these
wacky claims and who I think turn off
politically and it's really just just I
think a matter of giving people
confidence in their common sense because
that's what these conspiracies claims do
they do legitimate institutions and
diligent make political parties and
political opposition but they do it in a
way that offends common sense that's why
we're so disoriented by it all and I
think some confidence and common sense
that comes about by speaking truth to
conspiracism is the best thing we can do
we've been speaking with Nancy
rosenbloom Harvard University Department
of Government professor emeritus wrote
the book a lot of people are saying
co-written of course with Russell
Muirhead Nancy's such a pleasure having
you on I appreciate it and you were a
great question David thank you